[Applauso]
[Musica]
buona sera io vorrei cominciare queste
riflessioni
partendo da due fatti che mi hanno molto
colpito recentemente non perché non
c'era da aspettarselo dopo un'estate
calda come quella che c'è stata ma per
la rapida sequenza cui si sono succeduti
l'uragano harvey alla fine di agosto
negli stati uniti in dei carabi nei
caraibi e in texas
l'uragano irmen nei primi dieci giorni
di settembre a cuba ea miami in florida
e l'alluvione di livorno tutte queste
fenomeni dovrebbero aprire avere aperto
gli occhi alle persone che fino adesso
hanno fatto hanno sottovalutato
totalmente le conseguenze dell'effetto
serra dei cambiamenti climatici
purtroppo credo che dobbiamo aspettarci
ancora delle conseguenze più negative se
vedo se analizziamo i risultati della
coppa e ventura a parigi dove hanno
fatto passare come una grande vittoria
il fatto di essersi messi d'accordo su
una contenimento della temperatura
aumento della temperatura terrestre di
1,5 gradi due al massimo entro la fine
del secolo nel secolo scorso la
temperatura della terra è aumentata
rispetto all'epoca preindustriale di 0,8
gradi 1,5 e il doppio di 0,82 e due
volte e mezza
se 0,8 ha messo in moto i cambiamenti
climatici che ha messo in moto
io credo che dobbiamo aspettarci ben di
peggio
da questo tipo di aumento l'unica cosa
da fare è cercare non di controllare un
aumento ulteriore spetta con l'attuale
ma di diminuire le temperature terrestri
e siccome nell'aumento delle temperature
terrestri e influiscono prevalentemente
la rividi carbonica e il metano
bisogna fare tre cose sostanzialmente
primo ridurre la combustione di fonti
fossili per procurarsi dell'energia
secondo aumentare le superfici boscate
per aumentare la fotosintesi
clorofilliana che assorbe latine
carbonica perso limitare gli allevamenti
industriali il consumo di carne per
limitare le emissioni di metano è
evitare che vengono disboscate delle
vaste aree della superficie terrestre
per fare dei pascoli per gli animali
d'allevamento cioè quello che occorre è
questa diminuzione perché comunque
l'umanità ha superato il limite della
compatibilità ambientale non solo sulle
emissioni di co2 che quest'anno lover
shot day il giorno in cui l'umanità ha
consumato tutte le risorse rinnovabili
che la terra richiamerà nel corso di un
anno è stato il 2 di agosto
l'anno scorso era stato il 15 di agosto
dieci anni fa era stato il 15 di
settembre 20 anni fa era stato il 15 di
ottobre o si riporta il novero dei
progressivamente verso 31 dicembre non c
è futuro per l'umanità
ma pensate al fatto che in tutti gli
oceani che aleggiano masse di poltiglia
di plastica più grandi degli stati uniti
mentre la popolazione dei pesci si è
dimezzata pensate alla riduzione della
fertilità dei suoli che c'è stata c'è
tutta una serie di fenomeni che ci fanno
capire che l'unica soluzione per
affrontare questa svolta che può mettere
in discussione la sopravvivenza stessa
dell'umanità e la decrescita e la
diminuzione
perché tutti questi fenomeni sono
aumentati sono alimentati dall aumento
della produzione di merci dall aumento
dell'uso di risorse dall'aumento delle
missioni che vengono fatte nel corso dei
cicli produttivi
ora non c'è alternativa non è una scelta
la decrescita
ci si rende conto di questo che non c'è
alternativa che non c'è una scelta si
deve porre il problema di capire se è
possibile fare una decrescita che non
comporti un eccessivo peggioramento
delle condizioni di vita dei popoli
sviluppati che consenta un miglioramento
sottosviluppati e che possa garantire
una transizione dell'umanità ha perso
una fase storica di carattere diverso ma
per capire se questo è possibile noi
abbiamo innanzitutto crociera capire che
cos'è la cresce ed economica perché noi
siamo così abituati a pensare che la
crescita economica sia l'aumento dei
beni che vengono prodotti e di servizi
che vengono forniti in realtà
l'indicatore con cui si misura la
crescita il prodotto interno lordo è la
somma dei prezzi di vendita degli
oggetti e dei servizi ha un suo finale
cioè delle merci e essendo la somma
delle merci non ci dice niente sulla
qualità di queste merci
cioè se c'è qualche cosa che danneggia
che so gli incidenti stradali fanno
crescere il prodotto interno lordo
l'energia si parlava prima voi pensate
che per riscaldare i nostri edifici noi
consumiamo mediamente 20 litri di
gasolio o venti metri cubi di metano al
metro quadrato all'anno
il massimo che è consentito in germania
e 7 litri 7 metri cubi al metro quadrato
all'anno un terzo di quello che
consumiamo noi
questi sono gli edifici peggiori gli
edifici migliori consumano un litro e
mezzo al metro quadrato all'anno
allora tutte queste cose che fanno
crescere il commercio la 20 del prodotto
interno lordo non è detto che siano cose
che danno dei risultati di carattere
positivo per cui quello che occorre fare
è introdurre degli elementi di carattere
qualitativo e ridurre oggettivamente le
produzioni di oggetti
che non hanno nessuna utilità quando si
parla di nessuna utilità io non sto
facendo un discorso della teoria dei
bisogni
nessuno può permettersi di entrare nei
desideri delle persone anche se qualcuno
pensa che comprarono certo c'è il numero
eccessivo di vestiti o spendere i soldi
per qualche cosa di oggettivamente
dannoso come le sigarette che vede sia
un fatto negativo le persone che
desiderano prendere tante magliette
sostituire i cellulari frequenza fumare
delle sigarette comprare delle macchine
potenti hanno diritto di farlo perché
costui è comunque un esigenza di
carattere soggettivo
noi parliamo di problemi di oggetti che
sono i prodotti che sono oggettivamente
inutili quali sono i prodotti
oggettivamente inutili faccio degli
esempi il cibo che si butta nessuno
diciamo si desidera comprare del cibo
per buttarlo l'energia che si spiega
negli edifici
nessuno è contento di spendere il triplo
di quello che potrebbe spendere per che
spreca energia l'abuso delle medicine
le materie prime contenute negli oggetti
che vengono dismessi se gli oggetti che
vengono emessi vengono interrati o
bruciati si perdono completamente le
materie prime che contengono la
decrescita è la riduzione selettiva
degli sprechi delle cose che è
oggettivamente non servono a niente
non è un intervenire all'interno delle
scelte delle persone
questo diciamo così è uno dei modi in
cui si può ottenere una decrescita che
comporta un miglioramento delle
condizioni di vita
se le nostre case riducessero gli
sprechi di energia
noi potremmo risparmiare dei soldi
riduciamo le emissioni di anidrite
carbonica e diciamo l'effetto serra e
miglioriamo
l'abitabilità delle case questo è un
esempio specifico di decrescita felice
se si riduce lo spreco del cibo
diminuiscono i rifiuti diminuisce la
parte più difficile da gestire dei
rifiuti che quella putrescibile e si
riducono i costi la decrescita significa
utilizzare delle tecnologie più evolute
per ridurre gli sprechi di sostanze che
creano dei problemi
la decrescita non è la recensione molti
confronto ma decresce dalla recessione
non so se per malafede per ignoranza o
per che cosa
bene la recessione è la diminuzione
generalizzata e incontrollata di tutta
la produzione di merci sia quelle utili
che quelle inutili la conseguenza più
grave della recessione e la
disoccupazione la decrescita essendo la
diminuzione selettiva delle merci che
non hanno nessuna utilità crea
occupazione e l'unica maniera nei paesi
industriali avanzati di creare
occupazione un'occupazione utile perché
l'occupazione non è mai un valore di per
se stessa
l'ilva di taranto crea occupazione
creando i danni ambientali
le fabbriche delle armi crea un
occupazione aumentando le possibilità
delle guerre noi dobbiamo creare
occupazione di attività utili cioè dare
l'elemento di carattere qualitativo
bene oltre a essere un occupazione utile
è un'occupazione che non costa nulla
questo è un elemento che sembra quasi
paradossale ma facciamo l'ipotesi di
avere una casa che consuma 20 litri di
casuale al metro quadrato all'anno e che
questa casa venga ristrutturata e che i
suoi consumi scendono a 5 litri al metro
quadrato all'anno
vuol dire che il proprietario di quella
casa spende dopo la ristrutturazione un
quarto di quello che spendeva prima si
possono fare addirittura dei contratti
per cui le ristrutturazioni energia di
vengono fatti a spese della società che
le procure che fa e il proprietario
della casa
impegna a continuare a pagare la cifra
che paga oggi per un certo numero di
anni predeterminato contrattualmente in
questa maniera il risparmio serve ogni
anno ad ammortizzare delle quote degli
investimenti e sono stati necessari a
ristrutturare la casa cioè io quello che
non riesco a capire che noi compriamo
molta energia dall'estero molte fonti
fossili spendendo moltissimi soldi e che
questa energia per il 70 per cento è
sprecata in conseguenza di inefficienza
tecnologica in conseguenza di
irresponsabilità di comportamento non
sarebbe meglio che i soldi che oggi
spendiamo per comprare dell'energia che
sprechiamo rispondessimo per pagare i
salari e gli stipendi delle persone che
lavorano per fare in modo che smettiamo
di sprecare energia si può costruire
tutta una politica economica e
industriale
su queste cose il primo aspetto della
decrescita è la riduzione delle merci
che non hanno nessuna utilità
oggettivamente il secondo aspetto è la
capacità di come produrre dei beni che
non vengono comprati c'è autoprodotti o
scambiare sotto forma di dono nell'audio
di rapporti di solidarietà tra le
persone nella nostra famiglia noi
abbiamo da 18 anni un orto dove
costruiamo della frutta della verdura
che serve a soddisfare la nostra bisogna
diventare quella frutta con la verdura
non fanno crescere il prodotto interno
lordo perché non vengono comprate e
vendute fanno diminuire il prodotto
interno lordo
perché noi non andiamo a comprare la
verdura equivalente a quella che
produciamo per noi stessi quindi
facciamo diminuire la domanda della
merce frutta e verdura e l'altro aspetto
oltre la produzione e la capacità di
instaurare tra di noi di rapporti basati
sul dono del tempo sulla solidarietà e
non sulla competizione la concorrenza
come ha fatto fino adesso
la decrescita non è una è una idea che
nasce in campo economico ma non si
esaurisce in ambito economico è una
travalica subito in una concezione del
mondo in una concezione della vita
non è mettere il segno meno davanti al
pil
perché se si limitasse a mettere il
segno meno durante al pil non uscirebbe
dalla logica quantitativa di coloro che
vogliono mente il segno piu davanti al
pil è l'introduzione di criteri di
valutazione qualitativa nel fare umano è
un cambiamento di paradigma culturale un
modo diverso di impostare i rapporti
della specie umana col mondo e con i
viventi non umani e l'unico modo di
superare non solo la crisi ecologica ma
anche la crisi economica consentendo la
umanità di aprire una fase nuova
più evoluta della sua storia grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]